you know I liked me and I liked the
taste of savory meats but there's
something about jerky that just makes me
wanna vomit the road trip jerky taste
test with the try guys
we've been up since 5:00 a.m. we got
four hours to kill in the car let's eat
some jerky yeah thanks turkey jerky
quality tradition and the spirit of
adventure has been their way of life for
over a hundred years that's a lot of
years it's weird-looking it smells like
dog food hmm top like you'd expect but
the flavor pretty delicious
it reminds me of Thanksgiving dinner
where you're eating the little burnt
pieces of Turkey this was a hotmail
celeb turkey jerky would be Chris Pratt
because he's like totally doing what he
should be as a as an action movie star
but he's just better for you I like it
this guy is very confusing it's Bo
delicious Oh bodacious bacon jerky
sounds incredible oh I love how much
fats on this oh god it smells so pungent
best snack this side of the Rio Grande
that's not the bacon I expected if
beggin strips tasted like this I would
[ __ ] meet veteran strips
I don't hate it it's hot male celeb
equivalent is Channing Tatum because
it's kind of rich and fat but it's
always tasty this was bodacious the
original slim jim step into a slim jim
eat me okay it looks like a dehydrated
dick it's hairy on the end botanically
separated chicken poo paprika are we
just in a gloss over there
we separated chicken we have so far all
right or doozy for a food that's
described as a stick it's a pretty
decent food see - slim jims are like Sam
Smith they're gooey in the middle
there's something interesting about them
well you can't stop listening or eating
it you know 7-eleven original beef jerky
this is great cuz when I think quality
food
I think 7-eleven select it's a little
bit purple Purple's a fun color for
jerky looks like a quilt little tougher
oh man just crumbles in my mouth yeah
exercise not as good as the other ones
but still delicious ah this one by far
the worst 7-eleven roadie room done I
got I got nothing for this it just makes
me sad the hot meals love Vin Diesel
it's tough it's tough there's a little
leathery but everyone everyone can buy
joy apparently everyone else in the try
guys one dollar and 29 cents I don't
trust anything that costs less than two
dollars
this one's sweaty er than the other one
Oh sopping wet too wet too wet bursting
with flavor very odd but still but
weirdly sexy hint of spice this is a
horrible experience this is the benedict
cumberbatch there's something just
slightly off about him but in the best
way possible we've we've made a terrible
mistake maybe it wasn't the best idea to
open six packages of cured meat in a car
of men who have been sweating all day
but tomato tomahto you live with your
decisions and you smile throughout see
you next time on we're in a car eating
garbage